[Music]
every town across this incredible
country is someone's hometown and we're
highlighting as many as we can
like boston massachusetts where attorney
and mother of two anna foster calls home
and get this she created an organization
that helps budding female entrepreneurs
in her local area take a look
hi drew it's anna foster and i am
standing in front of wbz tv in my
hometown of boston i love boston because
it's rich in culture it's rich in
community and it's rich in innovation i
want to show you around boston so come
with me drew we're gonna have a great
time
right now we're at the seaport area of
boston and right at the site of the
boston tea party i love this area as i
was growing up it didn't look exactly
like this but as you can see it's
thriving and flourishing it has the
water it has the boats it has great
restaurants and amazing small businesses
hope you can visit the seaport area
boston one day you'll love it
so we're right here in city hall plaza
in the heart of boston and i have a
special guest with me
drum roll
the mayor of boston mayor kim janey is
right here standing next to me i'm so
excited mayor janie tell us about boston
and why you love this city anna thank
you so much and a shout out to everyone
watching
i love my city this is the city that i'm
born and raised in i am a city girl
boston is a great world-class city a
city of innovation a city of first we
are the birthplace of america the
birthplace of public education first
library the best hospitals in the world
the best universities public space
beautiful parks and i'm just so grateful
and honored to serve as the first woman
mayor the first black mayor of boston it
is amazing wonderful thank you madam
mayor kim janey
well drew that's a little bit about my
hometown of boston i cannot wait for you
to visit see you soon
thanks anna boston is wicked cool i know
i'm sorry i had to but i really do love
it i mean i'll never forget the memories
of being with the red sox as they broke
the curse of the bambino while we filmed
a movie called fever pitch and don't
even get me started about legal
seafood's clam chowder oh
i'll see you soon hopefully
[Music]
you